nieve
[Música]
avn y más
la gente
a diferencia de años anteriores fueron
pocos los fieles que llegaron a la
basílica de guadalupe para homenajear a
la patrona de mexico
el templo estaba completamente vacío
una más el hecho de estar aquí yo siento
que ella sabe que estoy que estoy aquí y
que ella está feliz porque soy uno de
sus hijos amados digo que nos vamos
contentos por haber venido y por otro
año más no podemos sentarnos aquí con la
virgencita pero visitamos un poquito
triste porque no nos van a dejar pasar a
su casa hacia adentro no a visitarla
lo que vemos a raíz de la crisis
sanitaria por la pandemia de kobe 19 en
mexico que se ha cobrado la vida de más
de 113.000 personas el evento de este
año fue cancelado y apenas unos cuantos
pudieron ingresar al interior del templo
que las condiciones sanitarias que vive
el país a causa del cobi 19 no nos
permiten en esta ocasión celebrar a la
virgen de guadalupe peregrinando juntos
a su santuario
y el bien de todo el pueblo mexicano nos
motiva a tomar medidas de contención
para evitar que el virus se propague
la morenita como también es conocida se
apareció de san juan diego el 12 de
diciembre de 1531 en el cerro de tepeyac
desde entonces la fe por la virgen de
guadalupe convirtió la revelación en una
fiesta nacional